[موسيقى]
منذ انطلقتها في اكتوبر الماضي في هذا
المبنى تساهم شركه مرواس بشكل كبير في
صناعه المحتوى والانتاج الفني في السعوديه
والعالم العربي دعونا ناخذ جوله في
استوديوهاتها المتنوعه
[موسيقى]
مرواس تضم اكثر من 22 استوديو متطورا يتيح
امكانيه انتاج الصوت المرئي والمسموع على
راس هذه الاستديوهات استوديو نيف المعروف
بصوته عالي الجوده ويعتبر مثاليا لتسجيل
الموسيقى استوديو اي اس اس الذي تم تخصيصه
لاحياء ارث الفنان الراحل طلال مداح
وتكريمي مساهماته في صناعه الموسيقى مرواس
تضم ايضا استوديو الماسترنج هذا الاستوديو
متخصص في تنفيذ المرحله الاخيره من انتاج
الصوت استوديو تدريج الالوان المتخصص
لعمليات تصنيف الالوان وتصحيح محتوى
الفيديو تم تجهيزه بشاشات عاليه الجوده
استوديو اي ام بي لمنتجي الموسيقى
الالكترونيه ودي جي والملحنين مجهز باحدث
اجهزه المزج والطبول ومحطات العمل الصوتيه
الرقميه
[موسيقى]
ما اعتقد اليوم انه في اي شيء
يعوق حركه نمو قطاع الترفيه والفن خصوصا
مع وجود استراتيجيه 2030 وجوع وجود جهات
ممكنه مثل هيئه الترفيه وزاره الثقافه
في هذا العمليه هو توفير مساحات استوديو
بجوده عاليه ممكن انها تنافس على المستوى
المحلي خلق ورش عمل لتنميه المواهب وايضا
شبكه انتاج تنتج الاغاني والبرامج وجميع
ما يخص الموهوبين
[موسيقى]
اكاديميه مرواس من ابرز ملامح هذا المكان
الابداعي حيث تهدف الشركه الى جعل هذه
الاكاديميه مركزا للتعليم الابداعي ورعايه
الجيل الحالي الاكاديميه ستقدم مجموعه
واسعه من ورش العمل والدورات التدريبيه
تحت اشراف مجموعه من المتخصصين لتعزيز
المحتوى في السعوديه طبعا دور مرواس في
هذا العمليه هو توفير مساحات استوديو ممكن
لها ان تنافس على الصعيد الدولي
واستراتيجيه الاكاديميه في مرواس اولا هي
الاستثمار في المواهب على ايدي محترفين في
مجالات مختلفه منها هندسه الصوت والميكسل
الماسترنج
وغيرها من
الكورسات الثريه والمختلفه ثانيا خلق فرص
وظيفيه تطمح مرواس الى خلق ما لا يقل عن
الف وظيفه في السنتين القادمه وثالثا
يعني المشاركه في ازدهار الاقتصاد السعودي
خصوصا بعد اعلان استراتيجيه
اللي هي الملكيه الفكريه الحديثه على يد
سمو سيدي ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
عبد الرحمن العصيمي لصباح العربيه الرياض
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات